les cherry on voit qu'il ya peu suite
avant de continuer ce qu'il ne fallait
pas louper tout à l'heure celui qu'on
appelle l'indiquent et j'ai un truc à
vous dire vous le savez pendant
l'émission tpm paix vous filme tout ce
qui se passe pendant les pubs parce que
vous n'avez pas c'est pendant ces que du
kif aux cigarettes non mais on a toutes
les images ce soir elles sont là les
images sont là l'indiqué la lundi
atteignant fait fait entrer lundi que
s'il vous plaît sacha rhoul indique de
la rédac
attention attention voici quelques
points on les garde à vue l'a fait c'est
plutôt un hercule piment comment ça va
ça chez albin michel base je suis
l'indiquent de l'adac série le bonjour à
tous aujourd'hui j'ai beaucoup je n'ai
pas moi
[Rires]
elle a alors voté j'ai besoin d'ailleurs
alors oui bonsoir l'indiquent de la
rédac vous ne connaissez pas vous le
vous allez connaître aujourd'hui
dac
je sais tout à paris voit tout et ce
soir je dénonce tout et oui j'ai pas
peur cyril ce soir je vais balancer
plein de dossiers sur les chroniqueurs
et je vais commencer par les zones
monsieur par ce monsieur
donc vous avez vu des choses sur lui
identité jean michel maire allez-y alors
ces grandes chaînes mères on le connaît
pour son professionnalisme
oui jean michel ah bon toujours au carré
sur les infos médias c'est l'un des
meilleurs bosseurs rien peut le
déstabiliser jean-michel sauf peut-être
une chose c'est le public regardez
des finances les ce soir bien sûr on a
notre membre du public
elle est magnifique qu'est ce qu'elle
éveille aurélia et la mer magnifique
[Musique]
obama lauréat le problème c'est qu'on
n'a pas de sens pas mal en rien le
problème c'est qu'elle n'a pas de sens
très très bonne valeur il ya le problème
c'est qu'elle a pas de scène pas trop
chaud la série qu'elle ragga c'est pas
possible j'ai rallye c'était même mieux
ce mois alors qu'ils permis ça je
voudrais dire ils se connaissent très
bien aurait gagné a déjà eu un truc
encore non non on est fait plein de
soirée en somme il s'est rien passé ça
aurait pu me suis rien passé avant cela
je me suis permis cette famille arrivée
assure une copine c'est une blagounette
poupe et ben voilà ce que vous auriez ce
sont ses mots soir ensuite ces riches et
que vous êtes choqués par ce genre de
comportement oui bien sûr franchement en
tant qu indique de la rédac je vous dis
aujourd'hui il ne vous mérite pas les
chroniqueurs ne vous mérite pas soit
parce que vous êtes un très bon parce
que vous n'aimez pas l'antique de l'anac
si je peux rentrer de suite à la
réaction des wayana medac
c'est plus une action
la première info basse est la seule à
pouvoir il ay d'orly vous êtes un très
bon patron ne vous mérite pas ah oui et
moi aujourd'hui j'ai appris j'ai apporté
la preuve j'ai apporté la preuve qu'il
est un très très bon patron
je suis beaucoup mieux sur le plateau
d'à prendre ou à laisser il fait moins
beau moins chaud puis surtout je vois
pas vos gueules regarder youtube vous
êtes des mythos ushuaïa rien par mon cul
monde le connaît
trois portions dans les eaux france mais
naim égale kaunas de france il n'en est
rien en réalité des français mais
simplement la vérité demeure rapport
toujours fait bienveillant parvenir ne
confirme pas mais c'est une chanson que
c'est un rituel ça fait huit ans qu'on
chanson alors l'adjectif change va rimer
avec là on attend un petit adjectif en
as il y en a d'autres
et j'aime beaucoup tout comme ça que je
vous aime ouais moi j'aime beaucoup
quand vous chantez mon nom c'est
affectueux et vous regardez pas du tout
de manier tout ça ça me rend fou mais on
les connaît la magnéto est à travailler
avant de venir
mythe ou maritimes quant aux
téléspectateurs c'est comme l'autre kim
dickens rédac a investi surtout pas les
autres sont pas idiots les ensablé chose
arrêter oui j'aurais arrêté très vite
cette chronique de mon stage parce que
là on voit vous êtes direct avec vos
équipes
ouais mais ils vous le rendent bien on
peut le dire là je peux le dire en
l'indiquent le dis vous le rende est
très bien à cyril surtout jean minutes
je vous remets un amour c'est bon c'est
mon chien géant mais on l'appelle le
lécheur le fayot mais peut-être que ce
soir en tout cas lundi vous a amené un
très bon et netto puisqu'il a peut-être
perdu sa place de leychert de faille
aujourd'hui j'en ai aujourd'hui vous
êtes peut-être détrôner impossible est
impossible il se situe sur ce plateau
[Rires]
jamais j'en peux plus je n'en peux plus
c'est bien depuis dix ans il a fait de
sa longue d'une force spéciale mer pour
servir jean michel a été reconnu par ses
pairs comme le lèche bottes numéro les
professionnels
après ses multiples interventions
remarquées des mères mais aujourd'hui ce
qu'il semblait être acquis sur le point
de voler en éclats à cause d'un
challenger toute personne n'attendait
son nom
serrés et bravo pour rire avec le temps
qui fait line on ferra millions sur un
jeu et tu vas continuer à la rentrée
sont immobiles s'étonne pas oui cette
patinoire et l'homme de médias mais un
peu suspect alors le plus ce cirque
immédiat j d'aujourd'hui ou de rimont
obtiendra la langue d'or seul claude
alexis le sait je ne sais pas je m'en
bats les x la baguette c'est mon frère
je connais c'est mon frère grave à
l'égard de jean michel
oui parce que jean michel c'est un fayot
mais c'est aussi parfois un escroc j'en
ai plus qu mais lorsqu'on le voit il est
toujours bien habillé toujours classe
etc
mais à votre avis comment gagne-t-il
tout cet argent pour est aussi classe je
pose la question aujourd'hui
comment fait-il comment gagne-t-il
autant d'argent et bien cyrille à
celui-là a su zahoui à la réponse est un
oui de quoi ah oui c'est quoi oui trois
ports et docks à l'époque les deux
frères il n'avait pas du tout ça n'est
pas d'apporter des tickets restaurants
comme anaïs co2 le chaîne en or qui
ferait n'importe qui ça qui était devant
avec une table comme ça qu'ils avaient
un attaché-case que ça l'argent et l'or
est utilisé donc vous avez dit on sait
combien notes de frais ce mois-ci oui
mais bon là ça nous apprend 2500 francs
jean-michel 1500 francs comme ça signer
s'ils n'ouvrent la maladie sortait de
lire ça il te donne et 2500 voitures
parquées ok je sors un bouquin a failli
doit sortir pour un confinement du coup
il sortira une c'est l'extrême sortira
en septembre avec yoann c'est aussi avec
you avec compagnies n'ont pas eu non ça
c'était pas fait avec eux non parce qu'à
la différence des déchets deux foyers
droit notre jeu et nous donner de la
viande à mes enfants ou mon job chez
nous ils ont eu la semaine suivante de
petits trucs au corps oui parce que
jean-michel on l'a vu il a beaucoup dit
allons parler de l'argent mais oui
visible à d'autres personnes il ya une
autre personne qui est très talentueuse
ici c'est géraldine il ya aussi les
insectes j'ai vu ça c'est que ce soit
dans ses cales histoire d'insectes aoula
l'histoire d'un mec là c'est un dossier
assez particulier parce que cyril où on
sait vous n'avez on peut enfin vous
réagissiez aucune provocation
dès qu'on vous parle on vous attaque
vous ne réagissez pas vous êtes un peu
au dessus de cyrille bien cyrille vous
avez un point commun avec un autre qui
ne se laisse jamais déstabilisé sait qui
c'est bernard montiel web et m mais
avant-hier il n'y a pas que le bronzage
qui vous lie ya les insectes les
insectes dans ces glover à tous les
les chéris je vous explique avec les
plantes et tous ici là c'est koh lanta
world is yours si on repart pas avec le
chikungunya offrait un atelier ses
impudences et année nous si je vois des
mousselines devons commencer tout
c'était des avions
sa mère c'est vexant que j'en peux plus
là des moustiques a été riche et toi
on fait un truc en une fatigue est là je
peux pas faire l'émission ces conditions
et enlevez moi les moustiques la selo
j'arrête là rocard donne alors une
dernière chose vous savez comme
d'habitude ils avaient bien changé le
conducteur donc c'est vrai que la
chronique a été un peu chamboulé mais ce
n'est pas grave puisque moi non plus je
suis comme vous je cède à aucune
provocation pourtant quelqu'un vous a
provoqué en début de semaine à céret
vous savez qui est oui oui je sais
géraldine maillet fait il la voyait lé
bella les gentils elle est talentueuse
elle est très cultivé mais surtout à la
une qualité elle est honnête et lundi
elle vous a provoqué vous a dit je vous
défie au tennis je peux vous battre
quand vous voulez alors vous comme les
plus grands joueurs de ce monde comme
rafael nadal
d'ailleurs son anniversaire et bien qu
est ce que vous avez fait vous ai dit je
vais y aller j'y vais jouer l'affronter
hélas ce qui devait arriver arriva
heures du matin hier au tennis pendant
deux heures je vous prends quand vous
voulez
vous croyez vraiment vous pouvez me
battre franchement en ce moment je joue
beaucoup
[Musique]
bien sûr parce que vous voulez
jour un coach vous serez tout ça tout ça
j'ai pas besoin vous prend 1,7 me battre
il a fait beaucoup d'amis aussi alors on
va tout à fait honnête vous m'avez
impressionné non vous êtes à la fois
percutant puissant dans ce robuste
on avait beaucoup de puissance dans
votre jeu et en même temps vous êtes
très vicieux vous avez bonnement et donc
vous faites beaucoup de chocs beaucoup
de petites balles merdique derrière le
filet c'est mal fait aux communes et
montfort le déplacement était nul il est
objectivement très fort parce que vous
avez su adapter votre votre jeu au mien
et à mes amis faiblesse medvedev n'ont
jamais avec lequel invitera les mégots
tous dans la vie tout court la force
dans les cuisses non mais non elle joue
très bien géré a dit le problème et je
dis aux téléspectateurs c'est comment
j'ai un jeu pourri et géraldine elle a
besoin de quelqu'un qui joue bien en
face et forcément moi comme je joue je
casse le jeu est là elle n'est pas
réussi à rentrer dans le match mais très
bien certains moments c'est ça
franchement wayne rooney 41e minute
quand même moins 45 minutes
et à chaque fois que faisait des double
fautes on avait fait deux vous avez dit
bien joué et géraldine impressionné donc
j'avais du mal à servir simplement
géraldine je sais que votre compagnon
croyons vous en plus votre non
franchement non pas du tout on m'avait
dit qu'il avait aucune chance très
acérées assez way we get ready avant le
vendeur il ya quoi ta défier cyril
baillie ambroise en tout cas gagné les
dix meilleurs on va jouer contre eux
mangent de civilité que tu vas tu
ni de près ni de loin mais serez gagnant
est ce que vous pensez vous pouvez
battre j'ai pas inoubliable savez moi
c'est moi je vous dis un match plaisant
à présent voilà moi je prends les
matches les uns après les autres
si diarra dernière s'est présentée
d'elle même de jouer avec moi c'est avec
grand plaisir
shakeel ans il joue très bien compris je
très bien mais voilà il joue très bien
maintenant si vous jouez vous même
impressionné 1 2 cuillère je me dis
attention il n'est pas cillé prenable
que ça mais ce que tu as réussi à faire
égalité avantage cac 40
il ya eu deux trois fois peut-être y
avait une balle de jeu elle a une balle
de match au mans séries à 15 15 août et
particules
géraldine vous avez un très beau tennis
bien plus beau que le mien je tiens à le
dire mais oui brousseau efficace mais je
vois je 15 elle arrive à faire être
bloquée fille casse et vous allez faire
le paddle avec le monsieur qu'elle est
belle genre survient samedi à venir
samedi vous avez 17 heures samedi bien
balisé bas je voudrais vous cherchez non
mais c'est vrai nom gérer tout seul
non j'adore me chercher au jet en
ambulance sacha c'est tout mon chéri un
petit dernier et veut pas partir de la
rédac n'amène pas des magnétos qui
concerne pas trop bien sur mac user
graphique à 50% c'était pour mayotte il
ya eu beaucoup jean michel et eu
beaucoup raymond parce qu'on a un avion
qu'ils étaient un peu des lécheurs avec
gmail mais ce que vous cyril ça ça vous
arrive de temps en temps comme ça une
fois de temps en temps de riches et pas
de lécher mais voilà d'être un peu fayot
ainsi défendre ça m'arrive jamais où ça
m'arrive jamais vous êtes sur wii
jamais vous connaissez la chaîne
non-stop people ça vous dirait de loin
je côtoie mclane à quoi ben oui pourquoi
visiblement vous l'aimez bien moi je
sais pas si vous regardez c'était dingue
ce top people launch of people on aime
beaucoup autant qu universal regarde
c'est le bon temps l'image est belle on
dit que l'image est belle
les belles images dites que vous aimez
la chaîne humaine de luxure non-stop bol
quelle image c'est une chaîne knbc
croyab le signal j'ai envie de le
recruter pour les prochaines précieux à
bien en stop et comme j'en ai fait
gagner
[Musique]
la base légale a dit judith a bien bravo
seul
[Applaudissements]